[Musique]
ça ton je t'aime quand on est ensemble
et quand vous êtes ensemble je t'aime
parce que tu es mon enfant c'est la
phrase mon tour où tout bascule
la jeunesse grande sacrifiée de la crise
pour certains jeunes la réponse est oui
tout ça c'est des gars chez les jeunes
les jeunes de 20 ans aujourd'hui c'est
difficile parce que les personnes
seniors
elle nous a vécu leur jeunesse pour moi
l'europe ça a été toute ma culture ça
fait ma personnalité
ça fait tout ce que je suis donc en fait
je rends hommage à mike richards
un sentiment que ne comprennent pas
certains aînés je suis né pendant la
guerre alors sacrifié on ne regardez pas
de sortir peut-être après 18 heures oui
et alors
je me sens bien dans ce style là mais
c'est vrai que depuis quelques temps je
reçois tellement d'euros marquées de
critiques que je me dis comme je suis
peut-être dans le fond tu as juste un
petit doute là nous sommes bien les sous
la même étoile
iam à supporter cette culture française
aussi un déplaise à certains qui les
mettaient de côté
en martinique on célèbre le carnaval
malgré la pandémie et vous le voyez dans
les défilés et bien on ne respecte pas
vraiment les règles sanitaires voire on
défie le virus ah oui a pas beaucoup de
masclat beaucoup d'enfants non mais bien
le vieux camp
ou pas le kit à quand je chante un air
mais comme un musicien et chanteur me
disais kunar est
j'ai envie juste de me retirer la sur la
pointe des pieds en désespoir de cause
en est allé sur un moteur de recherche
et on a tapé d'arman riz dans google
images et on tombe sur cette mosaïque de
darmanin qui d'après google riz la seule
photo c'est celle ci en bas à droite la
deuxième ligne mais c'est un montage
au bar de la garrigue aura noir et
marées noires est guère de boire car ça
casse un joli 4 qu'elle vient de quitter
sa qu'at-il à qui il a fait chou blanc
se grandit qu'avec cet arrêt non
tout le monde est sous le choc
tout le monde est sous choc rhône
helmand personne ne s'y attendait je
suis choquée mouche datcha clairement
déconner alors que le monde entier est
en train de se battre pour trouver le
vaccin le plus efficace pour lutter
contre la copie 19 la solution pourrait
bien se trouver ailleurs
1re espoir une plante venue de
guadeloupe appelé l'arbre de pique
elle permettrait aux cellules de se
protéger et d'être totalement hermétique
au virus
autre espoir le spray nasal exaucé des
24 développé par le centre médical
qu'ils raillent leur fille shiloh qui
auraient la capacité d'éliminer 99 avec
9% des bactéries présentes dans le nez
ça va permettre de distribuer du gel
hydro alcoolique sans lutter de shell
hydroalcoolique cible donc on a la boule
à développer geste est là tu appuies sur
la boule le g sort et à terme il va y
avoir une reconnaissance des gestes et
tu aura juste à faire ça comme spider
man
la situation s'améliore grâce à de
nombreux facteurs comme
l'intensification des mesures barrières
mises en place par joe biden ne nous
raconte pas des salades et l'aide
je suis la reine des saladelles arrête
tes salades ne m'étant l'assiette pas
dans la bouche
mme royal est donc même moi qui suis
plutôt un optimiste pathologique
je pense qu'on va traîner ce virus
malgré la vaccination pendant
certainement l'année prochaine et
peut-être encore un petit peu plus
longtemps à s'en va là la marque à son
volant peu plus la famille un peu plus
quand on leur demande à quel moment on
va reprendre une vie normale
on n'a que trois français sur dix qui
disent en 2021 un français sur deux dit
2022 ou plus et tenez vous bien un
français sur cinq dit on ne reprendra
jamais une fille normale qu'autre chose
à rajouter un non non non je trouvais
que votre habitation de la chambre était
habitée visite aux toxicomanes ni les
mêmes taux que les humains tranquillisés
maps assouan je dois vous avouer que si
ma voix est un petit peu et rallier ce
matin c'est en grande partie parce que
j'ai regardé mc sport il ya soit
probablement comme beaucoup d'entre vous
et que j'ai assisté à cette victoire du
psg qui fera date
vainqueur
un coup de main
calme toi quand même mon coco parce que
c'est pas la fête du slip en pâtit une
mère particulièrement émerveillés devant
sa petite fille
quelques minutes après sa naissance
extraordinaire grâce à la greffe
d'utérus réaliser moins d'un an plus tôt
c'est une joie immense c'est le summum
de la satisfaction
je vais tester son élasticité
regardez si ça tient le fric quand même
franchement je suis content
chan
il faut pas casser le poignet je crois
que castro le poignet faut que tu m'as
prennent c'est lourd ça travaille
sehnaoui quand je fais à nico comme s'il
en avait besoin
montre moi afin que je suis mais non
mais quelle faille ousseni qu ils voient
ça va je veux juste être sûr de bien
comprendre faut verrouiller le poignet
faut gérer comme ça voilà verrouille ton
poignet je trouve que cette volonté
d'établir un équilibre entre générations
identitaire qui à mon sens ça peut être
une des pratiques dévoyées dans inspiré
par l'amour de la france et de sa
sécurité et est absurde si on met au
regard de flat délit d'extrême gauche
qui ne sont absolument pas animés par
l'amour de la france
là j'ai compris qu'en fait nous c'était
un vrai vrai vrai player on a deux
pouces fredonner ce refrain entraînant
du plus grand tube de tonton david le
chanteur français de reggae est décédé
hier à l'âge de 53 ans
que de bons souvenirs avec lui et son
équipe par contre vous déconseille
d'essayer de faire un plan séquence avec
des départs synchronisée et des rastas
ils réagissent mal aux stress
généralement je me souviens de dire à
des bucs d'ouvrir les yeux et la bouche
pour le playback
les policiers de beverly hills ont
trouvé le moyen d'empêcher que des idées
aux deux en interventions soient
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux
dès qu'ils sont filmés par un téléphone
il diffuse depuis leur propre smartphone
une musique soumise au droit d'auteur
ainsi si la vidéo est postée le réseau
social supprime automatiquement le
contenu
c'est plate forme en effet dispose
d'algorithmes pour faire respecter nos
droits